[Musique]
on sort à tous merci d'être fidèle au
rendez vous quotidien de points de vue
comme son fidèle aux deux débatteurs
habitués du vendredi bonsoir faire
canadian soit vous êtes chargé d'études
à l'institut de recherche économique et
de la concurrence fiscale
l'iref et délégué général de l'académie
libre des sciences humaines et puis
guillaume bernard est avec nous aussi
bon soit sur guillaume vous êtes comme
tout le monde le sait désormais maître
de conférences à l'institut catholique
d'études supérieures de vendée vous êtes
l'auteur de la guerre à droite aura bien
lieu
c'est publié aux éditions desclée de
brouwer ont
on va commencer par parler des vinées
quoi pardon peut-être que vous en avez
assez mais franchement il ya des choses
nouvelles
on va parler de la pandémie bien sûr à
partir de ce soir minuit 16 départements
dont la totalité de l'île de france et
des hauts de france seront re confiné il
paraît qu'il ya beaucoup de franciliens
qui partent vers l'ouest est ce que
c'est vrai vous qui est allé gare
montparnasse aujourd'hui mais dans
l'autre sens pour nous rejoindre
exactement je suis arrivé ce matin il y
avait beaucoup de monde
déjà mais il paraît même que tous les
trains de ce soir vers l'ouest sont
bondées complet je verrai ça après un
rapport la semaine prochaine on espère
qu'ils me qui vous restera une place
mais vous voyagez pour raisons
impérieuses dont vous avez le droit
est ce que jean castex pouvait faire
autrement que de re confiné on va en
parler parler aussi de la spécificité de
ce nouveau dispositif
le principe c'est que on est confiné
mais on peut quand même sortir sorte de
confinement dedans dehors on peut sortir
mais attention pas pour faire n'importe
quoi
écoutez le premier ministre de même
rendre plus facile les activités en
extérieur ne doit pas être le prétexte à
barbecue entre amis à des regroupements
dans l'espace public ou dans les parcs
et jardins ou encore à des attroupements
devant certains bars qui servent à boire
ou à manger en vente à emporter qui ont
bien d'un côté un peu humoristique fois
je sais pas si c'est fait exprès
d'ailleurs de la part du premier
ministre sur le fond est ce que vous
comprenez ce dispositif tard en
confinement mais on peut quand même un
peu plus respirer que les fois
précédentes c'est mieux non
écoutez sincèrement je n'ai pas écouté
en direct le premier ministre parce que
j'étais en cour par vidéo hier soir mais
je les attentivement écouté après et je
dois dire que même à l'aide des
différents commentaires de vos confrères
j'ai pas très bien compris de quoi il
s'agissait
le en même temps macro n'y un qui se
révèle je dirais dans cette mise en
oeuvre de ce troisième confinement ne me
paraît pas évident on veut à la fois et
bien essayé de deux d'empêcher je dirais
les personnes de bouger pour que ça ne
vient
permettre pas là le virus de se répandre
mais en même temps on leur permet
d'aller travailler on permet aux élèves
d'aller à l'école sincèrement mais
j'avoue que je ne suis pas très persuadé
que ce type de mesure reçoit soit
cohérente
donc pour ma part je suis même par
principe hostile au confinement on
pourra y revenir et je l' ai déjà dit
dans le cadre de cette émission mais
alors là les mesures telles qu'elles
sont prises ou aujourd'hui et bien me
paraissent cohérentes les français
qu'est ce qu'ils en pensent regarder ce
sondage aux docks sable pour le figaro
et france info il a été réalisé après
les annonces du premier ministre et il
nous indique que 70% des français sont
favorables aux décisions annoncées hier
soir en revanche cette proportion
d'approbation baisse sensiblement pour
ceux qui sont concernés par les mesures
c'est un peu comme les impôts c'est
toujours mieux quand ce sont les autres
qui les payent
n'est ce pas jarry et seuls 56% des
français des 16 départements concernés
par le rpt confinement approuve la
mesure c'est toujours une majorité mais
on s'aperçoit que à chaque nouveau
confinement
ce taux d'approbation diminue chaque
année ziari le premier ministre avait
quand même des vrais arguments pour
annoncer ce confinement et notamment le
l'encombrement des
service de réanimation à l'hôpital oui
mais à qui la faute
moi vous savez j'ai été j'ai vu le
discours quand je les ai vus après j'ai
été sidéré de voir qu'il n'y a eu aucune
auto critique c'est à dire que vous vous
posiez la question
aurait-on pu faire autrement oui le
autrement s'appelle la vaccination
s'appelle la campagne de vaccination or
le fait qu'on soit obligé de recourir
aujourd'hui à cette solution extrémistes
acte l'échec de la politique vaccinale
du gouvernement là où d'autres pays
comme israël sont contraints de réouvrir
la plupart de leurs activités parce
qu'ils ont mené une campagne de
vaccination exemplaires j'ai les
chiffres sous les yeux hier encore si on
prend si on prend le nombre de doses
administrées pour 100 habitants israël
en est à 111 dose les émirats arabes
unis soixante dix doses le chili 42 2%
est pour 100 habitants
le royaume uni 40 dose les états unis 33
la france 12 et ceci dans le pays le
plus taxé du monde donc il est là le
véritable échec aujourd'hui du
gouvernement vous savez le plus le plus
frustrant ce n'est ce n'est pas tant ce
n'est ni l'échec du gouvernement ce
n'est même pas l'absence d'autocritique
c'est même pas l'absence de sanction du
personnel politique et administratif
détaillants
le plus frustrant finalement c'est que
tous ces dysfonctionnements
comme rien n'énerve plus personne une
espèce d'indifférence une absence de
volonté collective chez nous citoyens
français fait tellement de corriger ces
dysfonctionnements et là je pense qu'il
va falloir se réapproprier la question
institutionnelle pour inciter nos persos
ne nous nous sommes politiques à rendre
davantage des comptes parce que si on ne
le fait pas et bien finalement nous
mériterons notre servitude donc se pose
la question du statut de la fonction
publique pourquoi en dépit de tous les
dysfonctionnements qui ont été rapportés
recensés dans les médias par vos
confrères pourquoi n'y at il pas eu ne
serait-ce qu'un seul bureaucrates viré
pour le fiasco qui a conduit au
ralentissement des tests des vaccins à
tous les blocages administratifs qui ont
fait que cette campagne de vaccination a
complètement échoué
je pose aussi la caisse
bon je crois d'une dune red une refonte
constitutionnelle de notre régime c'est
à dire c'était plus possible d'aller de
dysfonctionnements en dysfonctionnement
avec l'impression que notre classe
politique ne paie jamais pour les
conséquences de ses erreurs
la qualité d'un régime politique ne
dépend pas tant des deux tiers de sa
capacité à éviter les erreurs parce que
nous sommes tous failli nous sommes dit
heureusement ce normal en revanche il
nous faut des institutions qui réprime
qui sanctionne l'erreur et on a
l'impression que ces institutions qui
n'existent plus nos internautes que
pense-t-il vous a posé la question
pensez vous que leur confinement est l
unique solution c'est non à 56 %
une majorité réelle mais quand même
assez courtes quoi encore sur twitter
nous dit peut-on vraiment parler de
confinement ça n'y ressemble pas bassi
parce que j'ai recours encore vous êtes
va ressortir votre attestation la
fameuse on espère que vous avez encore
du stock et puis brito attestation doit
donc toi tu es l'auto attestation c'est
encore non plus et due forme de
masochisme
jp du 69 sur youtube aurait préféré le
modèle suédois
une économie peu impacté et un taux de
mortalité inférieur c'est vrai que c'est
un point intéressant parce que on a
beaucoup critiqué les suédois qui ne
voulait qu'il faisait une sorte de
confinement là et tout un confinement
uniquement basée sur la volonté
individuelle sans contrôler le niveau de
mortalité a été très élevé et puis
semblerait aujourd'hui que il n'est pas
plus de morts rapporté à la population
que d'autres pays mais ça reste encore à
vérifier parce que la pandémie n'est pas
fini nicole 0,6 sur le figaro.fr ce qui
est incompréhensible c'est de
confinement mais avec sortie sans limite
de durée effectivement c'est le
confinement relatif martin sur youtube
on ne ferme pas toute une économie alors
qu'on devrait protéger simplement une
partie de la population les plus âgés
guillaume bernard comment expliquez vous
que même si c'est une majorité qui
diminue il ya quand même une majorité de
français qui approuvent cse cette
décision alors j'aime beaucoup de votre
question parce qu'effectivement c'est un
des points les plus importants c'est à
dire que la la sidération dans laquelle
est là
la population française aujourd'hui la
peur qu'on lui a insufflé alors qu'il ya
un taux de mortalité de cette maladie
qui est quand même extrêmement bas est
aberrant j'avoue que je suis extrêmement
inquiet et c'est le point sur lequel je
rejoins fergane alors que sur les autres
j'aurai d'autres éléments est lui opposé
mais c'est le point sur lequel je le
rejoins le fait qu'il y ait dans le fond
ils léthargie de la part de la
population une acceptation se dirait des
mesures qui sont prises qu'il n'y ait
pas de mouvement de contestation
semble-t-il visible même s'il me semble
quand même que dans la population ça
gronde un peu mais pas assez à mon goût
eh bien il est certain que si on peut se
poser des questions sur la réactivité je
dirais de notre peuple a encore et bien
être capable de refuser dans le fond des
mesures liberticides qui ne se justifie
essentiellement me semble-t-il que par
une volonté d'ouvrir le parapluie
juridique pour nos hommes politiques qui
veulent éviter qu'un jour eh bien il ne
soit susceptible et bien d'être mis en
accusation pour avoir pris des mesures
n'avoir pas pris des mesures qui
engagerait leur responsabilité juridique
et en particulier pénales donc vraiment
le fait qu' on est impressionné la
population qu'on ne l'aurait fait peur
et que du coup il y est encore
aujourd'hui une majorité de français
même parmi ceux qui sont concernés par
les mesures qui sont prises par le
gouvernement qui accepte cela c'est
extrêmement à mon sens c'est extrêmement
inquiétant
je serai encore beaucoup plus sévère que
guillaume c'est à dire que lorsqu'on dit
qu'aujourd'hui la population accepte les
mesures je pense qu'il faut renverser la
responsabilité moi je ne suis pas
convaincu que le gouvernement confine de
gaieté de coeur
c'est à dire qu'il ya quand même une
pression sociale très forte et moi je le
vois même dans mon propre camp vous
savez
chez les libéraux je me suis fait
insulter par mes propres 10 mai
con con collègues condisciples voilà
pour pour faire preuve d'une
intransigeance qui selon la plupart
d'entre eux ne se justifierait pas donc
j'ai bien peur que se pose la question
en fait de notre notre culture
collective de la liberté tout simplement
et vous savez ça pose aussi la question
des contre-pouvoirs pendant très
longtemps les constitutions avait pour
objectif de limiter l'arbitraire des
monarques vous savez pour éviter que le
despotisme d'un seul n'écrase la liberté
de tous
aujourd'hui se pose davantage la
question des consignes de la limitation
des pouvoirs des masses puisque c'est
aussi exactement c'est vieux comme
tocqueville en effet puisque ce sont
elles qui aujourd'hui demandent au
gouvernement effectivement de mettre une
camisole à tous les français et moi pour
quelqu'un comme moi c'est quand même
quelque chose qui m'inquiète puisque moi
qui habite de pester contre l'état je
suis aujourd'hui obligés de constater
que c'est de la société civile qui
finalement que vient la demande de
répression oui enfin tout de même il ya
un point c'est que la société civile
elle est influencée par les informations
qu'on lui donne or moi je suis sidéré
par le fait que finalement il ya peu de
débat sur le fait que depuis un an on a
eu des informations contradictoires
on nous disait que le masque était
inutile et qu'il fallait même surtout
pas remporté maintenance est absolument
obligatoire
y compris dans un espace ouvert y
compris dans la rue et
le les chiffres qui étaient pris en
considération au départ c'était les
morts et puis maintenant ce n'est plus
les morts se sont ceux qui sont
susceptibles d'avoir été des cas
contacts entre les cas contact de
personnes supposées être malade et puis
est ce qu'ils sont effectivement bord il
ya quand même une très large différence
et puis on le sait parce que c'est là le
point qui me paraît semble-t-il quand
même important le taux de mortalité est
extrêmement bas bien entendu il y à un
certain nombre de personnes qui sont
effectivement mortes à cause de ce virus
il y en a d'autres qui sont mortes avec
ce virus mais sans que la relation de
cause à effet n'était véritablement
établie
et puis enfin il faut quand même pas
oublier la pyramide des âges est le fait
que et bien les les personnes du baby
boom qui ont été donc des générations
nombreuses arrive maintenant à un âge où
elles sont susceptibles évidemment étant
donné notre espérance de vie de mourir
ce qui explique qu'il y ait eu un nombre
important de personnes qui soient mortes
mais sans que pour autant la proportion
par rapport à la population générale
n'est véritablement signifier une
augmentation véritable de la mortalité
donc non je ne fais pas partie de ceux
qui considèrent que le confinement soit
une bonne solution
aurait-on pu faire autrement oui depuis
le début on aurait pu soigner les
personnes avec un certain nombre de
traitements alternatifs
oui on aurait pu peut-être essayer de
jouer le jeu de l'immunité collective
et puis non en revanche non ah au fait
d'essayer d'imposer le vaccin et c'est
là où je diverge de notre ami fergane
c'est que je crains que les mesures à
répétition de deux contraintes
le couvre-feu le masque le confinement
ne soit fait
ou disons ne soit utilisé aussi pour
exaspérer la population et pour que
cette population finalement se disent un
jour il n'y a qu'une solution pour
sortir de cela c'est de rendre
obligatoire le vaccin ce qui porterait
atteinte si jamais cette vaccination
était rendu explicitement obligatoire ou
si elles étaient indirectement
obligatoire par le biais d'un passeport
sanitaire est bien ce qui porterait
atteinte et à l'intégrité des personnes
et à leur liberté
donc là je dois dire que
peu s'en être complotistes puisqu'il
faut bien lâché le mot mais en étant un
peu sourcilleux
on peut se demander si ces mesures de
contraintes ne sont pas faites pour
exaspérer la population pour qu au final
elles finissent par accepter une
vaccination obligatoire ou quasi
obligatoire juste pour corriger je ne
suis pas pour une vaccination
obligatoire puisque vous l'aviez suggéré
je ne suis pas pour une vaccination
obligatoire je pense qu'elle doit rester
facultative
en revanche la liberté leurs propriétés
implique aussi pour les propriétaires
d'établissements de fixer les critères
de sélection et d'entrée de leur choix
si par exemple un restaurateur un
propriétaire de restaurant
eh bien je veux protéger sa clientèle
d'une personne éventuellement non
vaccinés et bien sa liberté implique
induit aussi la possibilité pour ceux
qui le veulent les établissements qu'ils
le veulent et bien d'imposer des
critères de sélection sur la base par
exemple d'une patrie nation de la
clientèle ou du personnel qui y
travaille
vous avez la seule chose par guillaume
est la seule chose c'est que vous avez
bien que l'enjeu c'est moins la question
des établissements privés que les
transports en publics les services
publics l'école l'université etc
vous êtes tous les deux là ces critiques
c'est un euphémisme sur la décision du
gouvernement est ce qu'au moins voulu
reconnaissez le mérite ferghana ziari de
de ne plus décider de façon uniforme
pour tout le pays ça c'est quand même un
progrès l'idée qu' on regarde
département par département et donc le
l'espèce de monstre centralisateur et
jacobin et est rentré dans sa niche tant
mieux alors dans sa niche n'ont pas
totalement puisque son décisions qui
sont quand même étatiques et
déconcentrés alors pourquoi pas ce
serait que à tout prendre à tout choisir
entre un confinement uniformiser et
nationales et des décisions on va dire
plus territorialisée je préfère la
seconde solution ça c'est certain
maintenant on peut aller beaucoup plus
loin c'est à dire que la
décentralisation totale de cette
décision impliquerait je crois à la
restauration des libertés publiques ce
qui n'empêche pas ce qui n'empêche pas
ceux qui craignent ce virus de s'auto
confiné c'est à dire que la liberté de
circulation
n'empêche pas ceux qui craignent
effectivement ce virus de s'auto confiné
elle n'empêche pas non plus ceux qui
côtoient des personnes âgées pour motif
personnel et professionnel deux autos
confiné également c'est la solution
suédoise ans puisque l'absence encore
une fois de coercition ne veut pas dire
qu'on va faire le carnaval de rio il ya
même une juste mesure entre fait pas ces
choses-là la licence et la servitude
c'est à dire une res liberté couplée
d'une responsabilité individuelle
quelques commentaires d'internautes pour
finir et merci à tous de réagir sur
youtube ou sur lefigaro.fr en direct
ades sur youtube le confinement où le
couvre-feu sont de mauvaises mesures il
faut ouvrir des lits à l'hôpital c'est
vrai mais le gouvernement dit que c'est
compliqué parce qu'on n'a pas les
effectifs pour ouvrir des lits de
réanimation
alexandre sur youtube avec le
confinement à la fermeture des commerces
sont les plus faibles qui sont pénalisés
et puis avec respect quand allons-nous
traiter les cas positifs comme il faut
il ya trop de laxisme en france
vis-à-vis de ce problème un problème
dont nous allons probablement reparler
dans les semaines qui viennent on en
prend encore pour un mois mais ça c'est
le minimum parce que sans vouloir casser
le moral avant le week end lors des
précédents confinement les échéances ont
toujours été repoussée si généralisée et
génère parlons d'autre chose
même si ce n'est pas forcément beaucoup
plus réjouissant peut-être avez-vous
entendu ces déclarations de joe biden
à la chaîne américaine nbc c'était
avant-hier mercredi quand on lui a
demandé si le connaissez vous la dîmière
poutine et surtout s'il considérait que
c'était un tueur baden a répondu oui et
puis faisant allusion aux ingérences
semble-t-il avérée de la russie dans la
campagne américaine la dernière campagne
présidentielle où la russie aurait
semble-t-il à créditer des soupçons de
fraude dans l'opinion à travers
notamment les réseaux sociaux
hayden a répondu il en paiera le prix le
prix qu'il va payer nous le verrons
bientôt il a fait des choses
malveillantes
réponse de vladimir poutine s'est éteint
hier avec une expression qui apparemment
n'est pas réservé à la jeunesse ou aux
enfants français j'aurai le monde
derrière nous ajoute le bureau d'études
voilà sa légion sans doute à aux ravages
de la pandémie aux états unis ferghana
ziari le président baden il est dans son
rôle quand il attaque comme ça de façon
directe
vladimir poutine ou bien à votre avis
c'est une forme de 2,2 d'infantilisme
pour reprendre sa réponse c'est celui
qui le dit qui y'est ou de sénilité
dis-je
guillaume bernard toujours bienveillant
et non je pense qu'il est dans son rôle
alors moi je ne l'apprécient pas
particulièrement dubaï des néo
démocrates aux états unis mais je pense
en effet que nous devrions être exigeant
vis-à-vis de la russie qui est quand
même un régime qui pose problème sur sur
bien des points
moi vous savez je suis membre de teint
réseau enfin j'étais membre d'un réseau
des étudiants libéraux qui est implanté
partout en europe et mes amis en russie
vivre un véritable enfer c'est à dire
qu'ils sont régulièrement intimidé par
le régime est une vraie attaque contre
la société civile contre les libertés
civiles la russie fait partie de ces
pays qui ont complètement raté leur
trailer transition post-communiste à la
chute du mur d'ailleurs que lorsque vous
comparez la russie à certains pays comme
les pays baltes comme l'estonie voyez
bien qu'en matière de libertés civiles
d'état de droit en matière de deux
régimes politiques ça pays qui est
complètement échoué à bâtir un régime
constitué de qualité et l'occident ne
doit pas rester indifférent vis-à-vis de
ce problème donc comment je trouve tout
à fait bienveillant le fait que le
certains responsables politiques
américains ou européens face ces
remarques
à condition bien sûr de balayer devant
sa porte aussi c'est important de donner
de montrer l'exemple puisque vous savez
le prestige de la civilisation
occidentale de l'héritage libéral
constitutionaliste dépend aussi de la
volonté de l'occident et bien
d'appliquer ce qu'elle exige des autres
régimes
or là dessus depuis les révélations des
douars snowden depuis pas mal de temps
on sait que les le régime
constitutionnel américain a lui aussi
tendance à flancher un tout petit peu
c'est moins qu'on puisse dire
donc la meilleure manière de d'attaquer
un autocrate étrangers c'est aussi et
bien de de faire attention à montrer
l'exemple chez soi et la voix des
critiques du régime russe sera d'autant
plus crédible guillaume héras s
c'est le devoir je dirais même c'est
l'honneur des démocraties occidentales
que de pointer du doigt de telles
dérives
écoutez je crois qu'ils les deux quand
même important de dire des choses mais
de les dire d'une manière suffisamment
diplomatiques pour que ça ne crée pas de
difficultés inextricables
on peut parfaitement faire savoir un
état étranger
la désapprobation que l'on peut avoir
vis-à-vis de certaines mesures qui sont
prises dans un état sans pour autant les
déclaré à la télévision que moi j'avoue
que je suis un peu étonné on nous avons
dû un truck qui aurait été fou et
incompétents et de l'autre côté un bail
donne qui serait équilibré et
expérimentés il me semble que dans les
années du mandat trump on a eu à la fois
des états unis qu'ils étaient capables
de résister à la russie tout en ne
tenant pas des propos alambiqués de ce
type donc sincèrement
j'avoue que je suis non pas choqué parce
que à la limite que les etats-unis se
met en difficulté vis à vis de la russie
tant pis pour eux mais je suis en
revanche plus ennuyé par le fait que si
byden pense que c'est un moyen
d'empêcher la russie de basculer dans le
camp chinois
je suis pas certain que ça sera d'une
efficacité d'une grande efficacité
et puis il ya deuxième élément qui me
paraît important c'est que cette
propension qu'ont certains politiques et
en particulier aux états unis les
démocrates de s'imaginer qu'ils
incarnent le bien qu'ils incarnent la
démocratie qu'ils incarnent les droits
de l'homme ce que est ce ce cobaye donne
prétend être évidemment se logger
védrine appelait le messianisme
démocratique c'était une belle express
c'est une belle expression c'est juste
la présence du messie
qui mendient un peu mais enfin bon je
vois bien qu'il voulait dire il a il
avait et il avait raison
oui 7,7 traîne prêtes prétention cette
propension à incarner le a incarné le
bien il ya donner des leçons bah ça a
donné des résultats jusqu'à présent ces
dernières années tout de même assez
discutable la guerre en irak
l'intervention française en libye
je suis pas certain que alors évidemment
waida n'est pas allé jusque là enfin je
ne suis pas certain que ça ne soit enfin
je suis plutôt même certain que c'est la
même logique intellectuelle qui était à
l'origine de tous et de toutes ses
interventions et antoine sur youtube
prolongez votre propos en nous disant si
vladimir poutine est un tueur que dire
de joe biden qui a été partisan des
guerres des états unis sous obama dont
il était rappelons le le vice président
vous êtes 70 % à considérer sur twitter
que joe biden n'a pas eu raison de
qualifier
vladimir poutine de tueurs c'était trop
brut comme acquise à sion ajoute pâte et
chardons bleus sur le figaro.fr
de toute façon les démocrates américains
veulent un conflit avec les russes
depuis longtemps ils sont nostalgiques
de la guerre froide
ça c'est un point très intéressante à
gannat diaries est ce que finalement les
occidentaux c'est le cas des américains
mais peut-être aussi de nous mêmes nous
avons du mal à savoir si on a toujours
un ennemi à l'est donc j'étais les
communistes qui était l'autre ennemi ou
les russes
je pense que la nostagie d'ailleurs
froide allaient davantage du côté de la
russie je pense qu'à une grande partie
des dirigeants russes et poutine le
premier d'ailleurs il l'a déjà dit et
qui était nostalgique de la grandeur de
l'urss quand c'était encore une grande
superpuissance moi je suis pas certain
de l'utilité de ce que ce relativisme
que guillaume feront peut-être critique
de la politique étrangère américaine est
sans doute est elle très imparfaite
moi je vous avoue qu'à titre personnel
en matière de politique étrangère mon
coeur penche plutôt vers la suisse par
exemple mais bon je ne pense pas des
fois
opportun de renvoyer dos à dos un régime
américain qui malgré tous ses défauts
malgré toutes ses imperfections malgré
tout sa corruption offre quand même sur
le plan intérieur beaucoup plus de
libertés civiles que car régime russe où
les opposants disparaissent
mystérieusement ou une société civile ne
peut pas exercer ses libertés
démocratiques élémentaires sans être
inquiété par par le pouvoir et n'ont
donc ce relativisme qui est très courant
dans le discours d'un d'un hubert
védrine je ne comprends pas parce que je
ne pense pas que quelqu'un comme hubert
védrine aimerait vivre sous ce régime
poutinien donc l'empathie envers les
peuples commandes en effet pour
l'occident de critiquer ces régimes et
là-dessus pardon mais la politesse
diplomatique elle a aussi ses limites
c'est à dire que dire qu'il faut bien se
comporter avec les kleptocrates fin ça
revient aussi un peu à banaliser des
régimes qui encore une fois sont
d'origine dans lesquelles nous ne
voudrions pas y vivre donc il y ait un
ton dur des critiques acerbes
moi ça ne me choque pas je trouve ça
tout à fait simple on ne part relativisé
les régimes politiques qui peuplent ce
bas monde
alors je pense que l'on peut identifier
les raisons de notre désaccord
bien entendu le premier amendement aux
états unis me convient naturellement
mieux que un régime dans lequel est
peut-être même d'ailleurs le nôtre aussi
d'une certaine manière où la liberté
d'expression et de recherche ne sont pas
forcément totalement permise bien mais
pour autant la ici nous parlons de
relations internationales
ce que je constate c'est que byden est
extrêmement dur avec poutine mais que
vis-à-vis de la chine qui me semble-t-il
est aujourd'hui quand même plus
dangereuse que la russie il est quand
même un tout petit peu en deçà dans la
dans la formulation
donc c'est un peu simple si j'ose dire
des trous c'est peut-être trop simple
d'être extrêmement rude avec la russie
qui incontestablement n'est plus une
super puissance mais restait évidemment
quand même un état important et qui me
semble-t-il pourrait être un allié dans
bien des combats au niveau international
alors que par ailleurs
vis de la chine le discours est quand
même plus plus en de ça est plus mou
voilà je sais que je suis un lecteur de
soljenitsyne que évidemment j'ai été
impressionné par les positions qu'ils
pouvaient avoir vis-à-vis de l'ukraine
ou de kiev et que donc je fais plutôt
partie de ceux qui ont été convaincues
par celgene in fine par la rgpp sur
l'argument que effectivement c'est le
berceau de la de la russie pour autant
je ne suis pas toujours le défenseur des
positions russes
1 mais le fait de ne pas être toujours
le défenseur des positions rue ça ne
veut pas pour autant dire que les
intérêts de l'otan sont nécessairement
toujours défendable donc voilà je crois
que il faut que dans l'intérêt je dirais
de la france et de l'europe
eh bien nous essayons d'avoir des
relations apaisées avec les uns et les
autres et puis surtout comme dans toute
politique il faut établir de qui on est
le plus éloigné de qui on est le plus
proche en l'occurrence il me semble que
nos intérêts et notre civilisation est
plus proche de moscou que pékin est
évidemment plus proche de moscou que de
ryad
quelques commentaires de nos internautes
au minium sur lefigaro.fr un président
qui possède la force nucléaire est une
force militaire expéditionnaire a
forcément un job de tueurs et puis
chaoui sur youtube d'américains vont
comme d'habitude diviser le monde en
deux pour servir leurs propres intérêts
et celui de leur pays et l'europe va
rester spectatrice
joe biden considère qu'on ne peut pas
pardon nadia sur youtube considère que
joe biden ne devrait pas ne peut pas
même traité de but en blanc son
homologue même s'il le fait quand même
avant de montrer ses muscles de menacer
il faut avancer les arguments et être
sûr de soi c'est un peu prétentieux non
cobayes n avait évidemment probablement
en tête un certain nombre de de
disparition ou de mort mystérieuse de
d'opposants ou de journalistes russes
et puis à cette réaction de thierry sur
youtube c'est indigne
la phrase de joe biden traitant de
tueurs vladimir poutine quelles auraient
été les réactions dans le monde du
donald trump avait tenu ces propos
est ce que c'est le reflet d'une forme
de trump isation de la diplomatie
mondiale ce genre de ce genre de phrases
trump isation de la diplomatie mondiale
alors je ne sais pas je pense en effet
que moi il ya quelque chose que je ne
supporte pas dans les relations entre
chasse c'est l'hypocrisie c'est à dire
que l'idée que les relations
internationales doivent être forcément
poli bienveillant je suis désolé je
n'adhère absolument pas ce discours je
pense que pendant la guerre froide
si on avait été polis avec l'urss vient
peut-être qu'on n'aurait pas suscité la
chute du mur plus tôt donc moi je ne
suis absolument pas choqué qu'il y ait
comme mondial des critiques acerbes qui
bien soit émise contre tel ou tel régime
politique à condition effectivement et
là où guillaume a raison c'est qu'il y
ait une cohérence
on ne peut pas accepter qu'il y ait d'un
côté effectivement un traitement sévère
de la russie mais en même temps une
bienveillance et un silence coupable
vis-à-vis de pékin ou même une amitié
vis-à-vis de l'arabie saoudite qui est
donc le symbole du despotisme islamistes
et orientale et qui expose une idée aux
eti qui tend à propager une idéologie
qui fait des morts jusqu'à jusqu'à chez
nous donc il y a en effet eu une
cohérence à avoir une colonne vertébrale
idéologique à la fois sur le plan
intérieur et sur le plan international
et la légitimité de ce droit d'ingérence
idéologique pas forcément politique et
militaire c'est à dire critiquer un
régime politique ne veut pas dire qu'on
va l'envahir c'est simplement rapplique
qu'il existe des valeurs universelles
qu'il n'y a pas d'un côté des peuples
promis à la liberté et d'autre des
peuples
l'autre côté des peuples promis l
esclavage comme le voudrait par exemple
aristote mais qui est des valeurs
universelles tout simplement qu'ils
méritent d'être propagées par le
discours par la parole et par exemple
tout simplement
et bien voilà ce sont ces fortes paroles
que nous allons conclure cette émission
merci beaucoup à vous tous de nous avoir
suivi on vous souhaite un excellent
week-end et on vous dis à très bientôt
pour un nouveau point de vue
[Musique]